it is ambitious and it is a challenge to
the rest of the world today the european
union laid out plans to cut greenhouse
gas emissions 55 percent by the end of
the decade
it calls for phasing out the sale of
petrol and diesel cars by the year 2035
and it also calls for a carbon tax that
both the u.s and china oppose
critics say the plan places too much of
a burden on consumers especially in poor
european countries
environmental activists say the plan
doesn't go far enough
the moon landing in 1969
a historic day and an event that
europe's leaders have compared to
another historic challenge
the fight against climate change
we do not have all the answers yet
today is the start of a journey
but this is europe's man
on the moon moment the eu
aims to make europe the first climate
neutral continent by 2050
that means no more carbon should be
admitted into the atmosphere than what's
absorbed
for example by forests as a first step
on this journey
eu leaders have pledged to cut emissions
by 55
by 2030 but critics say
these cuts are nowhere near enough to
meet the goals of the 2015 paris
agreement
others fear less wealthy eu countries
and many of its poorer citizens
won't be able to afford the measures
the eu though has promised to help lower
income households
and fight climate change by introducing
a package of new laws
all right we want to cross over now to
tim gore in stockholm sweden he is the
head of the low-carbon and circular
economy program at the institute for
european environmental policy
that's a sustainability think tank
that's based in brussels
it's good to have you on the show tim i
mean this is an ambitious plan
that europe is presenting to itself and
the world
is it what is needed to meet
the promises and the pledges of the
paris climate agreement
well thanks for having me um the first
thing to say is that of course we need
always more action uh but this is the eu
uh
not only putting on the table a new
strengthened
climate reduction target by 2030 55
reductions below 1990 levels but
critically also
setting out a comprehensive plan to
actually achieve it
so that's a world first and what this
package is really built on is the
polluter pays principle it's going to
extend carbon pricing
to around two thirds of emissions in the
eu
now that's a good thing as long as we
make sure that the revenues it generates
and it's going to generate about 100
billion
euros per year by the end of the decade
as long as we spend those revenues well
we can both cut the emissions and reduce
inequalities in europe at the same time
yeah you say making the polluter pay i
know a lot of people watching will
wonder
does that mean making the consumer pay
more as well
well ultimately it will because in the
end if you ask business to
change what they're doing to take
account of the
carbon emissions that they're producing
what they tend to do is pass that on to
consumers so it doesn't matter in the
end whether you
try and regulate or whether you set a
carbon price consumers will have to pay
now the advantage of doing this with a
carbon price is that you will generate
substantial revenues
in the process so the really critical
question is how you then use those
revenues to make sure
that the poorer citizens are not bearing
the burden so i think it's important
that the commission today has set out
some initial plans for a
climate social fund that's going to
generate billions and direct those
towards some of the poorest
households across the eu to help them
with the transition
this is all about you know embedding
fairness at the heart of proposals i
think what we've had today is a start
and now we need to build on that and tim
i've got about 30 seconds let me just
ask you
there are 27 members of the european
union well these measures have to be
watered down before we finally get an
approval by everyone well
inevitably you know nobody gets
everything that they want there's also
the european parliament to take into
account they'll have views on everything
as well
i think the key here is it's a package
deal so you're going to have
horse trading but as long as politicians
can sell this
to their publics to show that actually
this is going to be good for their
health it's going to be good for jobs
and it's going to make sure that we have
a safer climate both for our current
generations and for future generations
if they can do that i think that the
package will get through
tim gore with the institute for european
environmental policy tim we appreciate
your time and your insights tonight
thank you
thanks
you